ready for this Lao posturing will not
help I can back it up then me
you bar my way authorized personnel only
consider this my authorization ring fart
Sub Zero do not test me
I merely hope to learn from you fine
that's far enough that is for me to
decide fraid not princess yeah
such Ruby said hate I infringe upon your
territory
I'll show you its power
such bitterness and hate I am fringe
upon your territory you imprison
yourself katana then fired
Lin Kuei you will know the sting of
winter
Jimmy's son of kimchi shirai Ryu don't
fear Lin Kuei a serious error in
judgment when you fart
Sub Zero let's talk you need weapons to
talk we go with the outfit
poor Jin what is it now you're gonna get
beat up for it
what is your purpose here you could use
a friend like me you've nothing to offer
when we fight
but you shouldn't be here you question
me okay
why an ass for a face when we formed
are you loyal to anyone I'm adaptable
those you betray see it differently
round one fight
our service ends now you desert me
we killed you then walk fight
insane child tell them smashed or fort
stand aside Titan I will see you again
shortly thank you for it
Lord Rayden have foreseen your defeat
your predictions failed to impress wrong
one fight
you
you